facciamo che tagli tutte le parti dove è
fatto pregare così che ti faccio fare
bella figura
va bene ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
puntata di cucina buttata all'interno
della mia cucina la grande bettola oggi
ancora una volta dimenticheremo il
grembiule e nico è colpa tua se non
dovete in più c'è poco da fare
capito ma glielo scordato a casa sì per
un mese dopo 8 come basta che porti la
testa è colpa mia perché non ho detto
enrico di portare tecniche non eri con
respira è la base che te lo dimentichi
oggi facciamo una ricetta facile
facilissimo per la colazione
stiamo parlando dei pancake con lo
sciroppo d'acero di oggi non sta
vestendo mimetico quelle che vedete
sudore
sapete che per la fine di questo
shooting secondo me non mi ha mai detto
sarà diventata da grigio chiaro e grigio
scuro vi chiedo scuro non commentate non
fatemi sentire i pancakes avremo bisogno
di due uova zucchero farina burro
mi raccomando il burro deve essere
presente nel vostro frigo da molte
settimane e deve essere diventato giallo
fuori quindi dovrete pian piano scavare
come degli archeologi alla ricerca del
burro che ancora chiaro dentro attenti
non vengono lievito latte e poi lui lo
sciroppo d'acero
ma questa portata gianni inter versarlo
mettete il campo nel piatto e versateci
versate punto togliamo tutto e iniziamo
la ricetta la ricetta con me è una cosa
devo fare
e molto semplice come ricetta però giuro
ma non so farla ti voglio bene farina 00
126 milioni
la prima cosa dobbiamo fare è pesare il
burro che poi dobbiamo sciogliere in un
tegamino io aborro il fatto di usare un
tegamino in questo momento quindi lo
sceglierò nel mio meraviglioso microonde
che all'interno di questa casa risiede
nel punto più alto ossia insomma il
frigorifero
che non c'erano dei veri posti in cui
inserirlo lista vorrei cercare di
sprecare il meno che avevo sentendo
sporcare troppe cose
ecco se volevo dire un calice di burro
23 addirittura c'è la linea è vero non
hanno detto vai la puoi fare pipì
tranquilla giammarco non si è mai fatto
problemi a fare pipì mentre giriamo 25 g
tutto bene rai pur birra il burro
stanley aspettiamo che sin tipi di ska a
sto punto
mettiamo i tuorli da una parte e gli
albumi dall'altra che faccio mettevo le
mani sulla fiamma e sciogliete il burro
con col calore umano di vini dove ci
farà una frittatina mamma mia lo so ma
sto aspettando potere distruggerli o no
voglio vedere che cosa diventano e
iniziano trasparenti ora stanno
iniziando a prender corpo nella ricerca
semplicemente zola ho giocato ho
lasciato che è troppo grande e forse ma
non ci interessa il burro agente pd dopo
molte ore
tra l'altro niente
più freddo io sono verso la ricetta è
particolarmente facile ve lo dico subito
ok sì la consistenza e molto molto bella
[Musica]
mamma mia la venia lascia stare però
hanno detto una cosa saggia usate dallo
stesso bicchiere burro e misurate 200
grammi 290 bravo gianmarco è ovvio latte
a filo montato il composto finché non
risulterà chiaro è chiarissimo pesiamo
la farina direttamente in questo
bicchiere bicchiere apriamo è iniziato a
inserire la parentesi verranno certi
grumi farina 125 si attaccherà ovunque
già lo so 128 mi è rimasto il servizio
quello della regina è un composto di
colpo arrogante di ray cooney delle vere
la farina setacciata duarte qualcuno
nello scorso video ma ha chiesto da ho
comprato questo che praticamente si
trasforma da così a così
se lo trovo vi lascio il link in
descrizione dove comprarlo dobbiamo
montare gli albumi zucchero le dita 3 2
1 non è successo niente
[Applauso]
a noto dove sfruttando le fruste ripreso
tutto
facciamo finta di averli messi album
[Musica]
chiamato media boom come si montano
degli albumi senza famose si allontana
entra come se va bene è stata frullata i
suoi pezzi non ci credo ma è una
tragedia questa troviamo un modo
alternativo come si montano degli albumi
in maniera alternativa al polso corso
celo celo celo celo no ma tu non so se
hai visto che cosa è successo ora vengo
aggredito perché sono completamente
spaesato certo una variazione del
consiglio
[Musica]
molto sulla sinistra
chiaramente no cioè meno che sembra un
po per fare il ci devi agitare a ragazzi
importantissimo messaggio se doveste
fare una cosa così dopo poi sciacquate
la bottiglietta buttatela nella plastica
che non butta nell'indifferenziata che
già di plastica ne abbiamo fin troppa
passiamo ai fornelli e ricoh seguimi
gianni volta questo della carta di new
york peso format avuto un crollo ma lo
zucchero non ho mai messo a caso
zucchero ha messo negli album i rossi a
farne ammirare mettiamo zucchero occhio
poco ma io adesso vi farò vedere un
procedimento di banking pazzesco è cioè
non è che sto dando per fare un qualcosa
di meglio
scadente ok non so se allora quindi
[Risate]
non ho mollato il cosina interno questo
è un diritto
un divieto che sorrideva tanto celato
nvidia nelle forza ma vabbè dai seri
mangiate mi piacciono lo ammazzo
[Risate]
enrico poi non puoi fare niente non puoi
vivere non prendono sorridere
questo è stato un ottimo merlo
[Musica]
ok hai capito come fare azienda cosa
seria o a un ciuccio noti ma nel sette
a me a una pompa a un robot nello
oggi un bene
un fungo bravo un tubo
adesso una buona
mai coperto quello brutto è
aveva detto che non avremmo sporcato
nulla da meno secondo
ecco qui il risultato della mia sfida
con me stesso un lavandino carico dopo
il primo e unico
no perché hai tutto uno sul piatto così
normali sono bagnati stickles 9 inter
nella prima volta lo sai come assaggiano
park di una maglietta giallorossa da
ormai piu che sorprenderà perché è un
cretino ma non vi è che poi non fu
gigante buono massone salato seppure
sono passate più buoni non ha certo se
lo zucchero si sono salvati però spacca
devo dire fatto un lavoro che è stato
pari a stati non lo faremo i piatti
un'arma che ricordiamo so cosa intonato
e permeabile certo mastica per passione
siamo arrabbiati questo video se ti e
piaciuto come sempre lasciarmi un
pollice su per i li scrive
la prima tela capraia tipiche lasciare
un commento per dirci che ci volete bene
esistiamo in questo stamberga ceniamo un
appassionato di nika sempre alle 13 con
1 episodio di cucina buttata nella
pentola
ciao io
con quelle gare in culo di enrico rava
verso quello mini da parte